when did the electronics industry get it started
what are some services it performs today how do
electronics lead us into the future one of the
earliest broadcasting stations primitive equipment
like this marked the practical beginnings of
the age of electronics theoretical scientific
discoveries dating back to Benjamin Franklin
provided the foundation but it was the time
and money invested by radio pioneers of the
nineteen twenties that first made electronics
useful sending through the air to homes near
and far the sounds of an and information
less than 25 years later television pictures
were being sent through the air and were
reaching [ __ ] an amazing achievement but
only one of many in the electronic industries
brief history for example there is radar the
same industry that first made it possible
for ship's crews to talk to each other and to
shore station gave the navigators the ability
to see through fog or darkness showing them the
position of other vessels rocks and shoreline
air travel - is safer and smoother because
radar lets the pilot see the weather far
ahead lets him maneuver around the store on the
ground meanwhile other radar installations keep
track of the approaching planes helping control
tower experts guide incoming pilots to perfect
landings even when visibility is poor at
the same time of course only electronics
makes possible the traffic control techniques
that permit today's heavy volume of movements
without electronic large-scale round-the-clock
air transportation would be impossible for
without electronics the closely-spaced takeoffs
and landings required to not even be attempted
the radar used in our air route traffic control
centers gives a picture of all planes within a
hundred and twenty mile range permitting the
controllers to maintain proper separation
on city streets electronics helps control auto
traffic at many intersections here in Wayne
County Michigan for example drivers are held back
or speed it along by lights that receive their
orders by means of radio signals from a central
office an aerial a radio receiver and a device
that will decode a variety of tone signals are
mounted on each of the lights in the network which
can be extended for a radius of 30 miles from the
transmitter atop a Detroit office building the
need for expensive installation and maintenance
of underground connecting cables is eliminated
a more familiar use of electronics is the police
radio involving mobile transmitters like those
now widely used by taxi cabs trucking systems and
even private citizens who can hold office or home
from their cars as easily as the policemen can
talk to headquarters the industry responsible
for the thousands of electronic devices now in
use did not even exist 40 years ago yet today
it is the nation's fifth largest manufacturing
joke its investments having created jobs for
more than 700,000 Americans whose work ranges
from the Assembly of large complex devices to
the manufacture of the smallest component parts so
great is the demand for electronic components that
some 3-thousand small businesses are engaged
in turning them out that's about two-thirds
of the total number of companies now engaged
in manufacture of electronic products whose
value totals more than eight billion dollars a
year there are plants in virtually every state
in the Union with heaviest concentrations on
the east and west coast and in the Midwest
their output goes to three major markets all
industrial and most importantly national defense
in today's defense system our ground
forces could not operate effectively
without electronic equipment any more than could
our intercontinental ballistic missile that's why
30% of Uncle Sam military procurement budget
goes for electronics more than five billion
dollars a year they are clothes designed to
give us timely warning of an aggressor its
earliest move rely on electronics and so do
the supersonic planes and the missile ships
ready to respond on an instant notice
electronic communications are the Nerds
electronic computers the brains for high speed
retaliation all branches of our armed forces
depend on electronic equipment turned out by
an industry that devotes half its production
facilities to defense without failing in its
civilian role among the many electronic devices
now available for the home is one that will open
the garage door at a signal from a dashboard radio
there's a variety of home electronic systems
television now brings programs to 86 percent
of the nation's 51 million homes many
with more than one set fast electronic
cooking employs microwave improved radio
receivers now are found in almost every
role and music reproduction at home now
is frequently stereophonic and you will
sound for maximum fidelity not so well-known to
most of us is the work electronic devices are
performing for industry the continuous weighing
of material for example right on the conveyor belt
Jordan filling and measuring of many kinds these
two are handled by industrial electronics thus
saving time and money increasing productivity
and income for all while promising even greater
progress in the future here's a demonstration
of the way electronic controls are linked to
a machine tool the magnetic tape is filled
with instructions which it passes along to
the tool in the proper sequence over and over
again as often as the tape is repeated the
tireless machine will do the job each time in
precisely the same way it did before accuracy
is assured errors are eliminated sometimes a
number of complicated operations are linked to
the electronic controls which may even have the
ability to detect and correct their own mistakes
should trouble develop they can shut off the power
or better still flash a signal that a particular
tool needs replacement before trouble occurs
no vas is industries use for electronics that
we can only sample a few highlights in this
power plant an industrial television system
transmits to the control room a continuous
picture of the roaring fires and the boilers
here electronic equipment helps the search for
oil by measuring the speed and ports of shock
waves from controlled explosions geologists
can learn about earth straighter down below
and electronics promise an important boost for
learning through the growing use of television
in education the system installed at washington
county maryland employs central studios which can
serve several schools like this one where TV seems
to have encouraged rapt attention while there's
no thought of eliminating classroom teachers
it's believed they'll be aided greatly by the
new teaching tool with its promise of improved
education for tomorrow's leaders meanwhile other
future promises of electronics are taking
shape in the laboratories whose research
the industry regards as its lifeblood in such
labs the transistor was developed and is being
constantly improved in the midst of countless
other projects a home tape recording machine
that will tape TV programs is among them and
so are fundamental studies probing scarcely
explored paths like solid-state physics to probe
the future electronic companies spend heavily on
research newer firms sometimes reinvest
all their earnings in growth the general
more profits more jobs new products and Amaral
products incidentally are many which have
materially hated research in other fields the
electron microscope for example has become a
basic tool in medicine today the medical research
underway at facilities like the Walter Reed Army
Medical Center in Washington makes extensive
use of a wide variety of electronic devices
these permit researchers to follow the progress
of radioisotopes for example through various
parts of the body thus revealing much we didn't
know before about the cause and cure of disease
more than 1 million persons have been
diagnosed or treated so far through the
use of radioactive isotopes and the related
equipment that makes them useful in addition
the electronic industry provides for the
medical profession such things as cardiogram
and diathermy machines and even devices
that will keep rocky hearts beating steadily
in medical educational a color TV camera linked
to a microscope from its simultaneous viewing
by large audiences surgery is televised too
and doctors now are learning for the first
time with the help of this device exactly how
much radioactivity the body contains normally
and how much it can tolerate the equipment
is called a liquid scintillation counter
and it's big enough to completely enclose the
subject who is rolled inside on a canvas hammock
after the chamber is sealed the medical officer
can estimate identify and localize all elements
in the patient emitting gamma radiation only
by knowing the dynamic levels of radioactivity
in man himself can the overall implications
of the international nuclear energy program
be followed and eventually evaluated as a
matter of fact nearly everything nuclear
depends on electronics here cables from an
experimental reactor lead to a control room
in a trailer park safely half a mile away from
this vantage point the technicians can start
the chain reaction electronics helps control
record and study the reactors progress as the
temperature rises generating steam in a related
boiler and finally creating enough electric
power to supply a small city TV screams eat the
control room fully informed meanwhile electronic
devices are performing their most spectacular
feats in the exploration of outer space doping
put the satellites in orbit and giving those
satellites the ability to report their findings
gathered by tracking antennae the record of each
flight and probe is captured electronically by
a complex telemeter ring equipment already
electronics provides the key to preliminary
space explorations by Radio Astronomy as well
as by rockets and satellites tomorrow it will
provide worldwide television and other new
forms of international communication even
communications between the planets opening
our newer aids of untold Marvel's to come